les parents d'alexia leur fille et leur
gendre sont donc présentés sur les coups
de 9 heures ce matin au palais de
justice de besançon ils étaient
accompagnés de leur conseil m florent
une source proche del'enquête nous a
confirmé qu'ils étaient convoqués par le
juge d'instruction à charge de la sphère
d'alexia pour répondre à ces questions
cette convocation fait bien sûr suite à
l'audition du principal suspect johnatan
davanne mercredi dernier alors les
supputations vont bon train quant aux
déclarations qu'aurait fait le jeune
mari de la victime les rumeurs les plus
folles circulent notamment celles
d'interpellation de plusieurs personnes
dont le dossier des rumeurs formellement
démentie par madame le procureur ce
matin à l'heure où je vous parle la
famille d'alexia n'est toujours pas
ressortis du palais de justice les
avocats de john attah navale pour leur
part confiante qu'ils tiendront une
conférence de presse dans la soirée pour
faire le point sur une affaire
décidément très complexe qui fait
beaucoup parler et dont on nous promet
qu'elle n'a pas fini de nous surprendre